when you write screenplays with jeff who
usually comes up with the idea
a lot of the times it's me i come to him
with a bunch of crap
and he goes he looks it over and he goes
okay
let's let's take this piece and then and
then it becomes more
back and forth with each other um he
does have you know he comes up with a
lot of great ideas and there's i know he
has a lot of stories that he wants to
tell
and he's really really good about you
know if he just wants to write a script
he goes
and he'll do it and then he'll pass it
to me and i'll read it over and
i'll you know throw in my two cents and
we'll start with so i feel like we do we
work a lot and we work really really
well together
in that aspect but it's definitely
i'm the one who pokes and prods him a
lot more to be like
hey let's do this or let's do that or
let's do this and he's you know he
he uh patiently deals with me
where do these ideas come from a lot of
them just stem from
stories that i would love to see
as a as a filmmaker that i would love to
go to the movies and watch
and you know a lot of them comes from
movies that i've watched over and over
and over again or
or you know a lot of the inspiration
comes from from movies in general
you know you watch a scene and you think
to yourself oh you know what well that
would be really interesting to it
even even a line of dialogue that a
character could say you know you take
that and go you know
that in itself could be a story like
that's something would be interesting to
explore so
we just try and find things that that we
would love to see as as filmmakers and
writers
and and and stories that we would we
would love to to
to be told you know i think you said
earlier that you've seen many movies
many many times and that's
something that you do is you rewatch
them what's one movie you've watched the
the most out of all of them
i'm looking at all the movies on my
shelf here on my buyer
thinking all of them uh i think one of
the movies that i watched
a lot over and over and over again
were films like star wars and indiana
jones
um i watched
king kong religiously like it was my job
um lord of the rings is something i've
constantly watched
uh i would suggest the behind the scenes
of lord of the rings to
anybody that can either can't afford to
go to film school or wants to learn
about filmmaking because it's like film
school in a box
it's the behind the scenes of that is
something that is that is incredibly
educational
but yeah i think uh a lot of those
films i would study and watch over and
over and over again and
i would say king kong is probably the
one that i've seen
at least 50 times a year
whether it's the sit down and watch the
whole thing or whether i just like
think about a scene that i want to watch
or that a moment that i want to see or a
piece of dialogue that i really
really loved so it's it's constantly
being
digested all the time you'd mention that
certain lines of dialogue would make
great
a great film in itself oh yeah yeah
can you can you give some examples what
uh maybe one which movie had the
greatest dialogue like one line between
someone that you wish you could then
turn into a feature film
oh yeah i mean sure um oh there's a ton
put me on the spot here huh uh i think
he had to be at hello
i know right yeah you had me in hello
there's
you know there's actually a really
interesting
old canadian movie i say old
it was about the late 90s and it was
called when good ghouls go bad
and it stars christopher lloyd who is
one of the most
amazing actors it's a it's you know
everybody knows him as doc brown and
back to the future but a lot of his
stuff
his serious work and his comedic work is
is just
fantastic so but he has a he has a line
where he's speaking to
his son and his son basically says you
know you used to be
this go-getter you used to be you know
and the town is dealing with the death
of this kid who
he got stuck in this like kiln overnight
and the dad and so the the town sort of
deals with that heavy weight
and the dad basically says you used to
be happy you used to be
um a go-getter you used to build things
and make things and
and help people and that and christopher
lloyd says yeah and i built the kiln
that that kid died in
and it's one of those moments in that
movie where you know you don't need he
didn't need to say that that didn't need
to be a part of the movie but it was
and that right there you look you go oh
man like that in and of itself dealing
with
the trauma of of
of doing something you love and then
that thing you love kills somebody
you know that in of itself could be an
incredible story so yeah there's a lot
of a lot of things in movies and i i try
my best to write them down when i
when i feel them and i see them and i
hear them but that would that would
definitely be a an example of something
that is all that has inspired me
yeah i love christopher lloyd i mean
taxi was one of my favorite shows
growing up amazing yeah he is great he's
an incredible
incredibly underrated actor i don't want
to say he's underrated because i feel
like he's not underrated but he
a lot of the stuff he does has gone
unseen by a lot of people
and he's phenomenal
you